[موسيقى]
موت في الارحام اعداد الاجنه المتوفاه في
ازدياد
[موسيقى]
وفاه مليون طفل من مضاعفات ما قبل الولاده
اطفال وان نجوا يولدون مبكرا غير سليمين
حاله طوارئ صامته اطلقتها منظمات انسانيه
اعلنت عن 152 مليون طفل ضعيف في العقد
الاخير
نحو ثلاثه عشر مليون و400 الف طفل ولدوا
مبكرا في 2020
سبب رئيسي للوفاه تحت سن الخامسه
[موسيقى]
وفاه اكثر من واحد من كل خمسه اطفال بسبب
الولاده المبكره بعواقب صحيه
مستوى الدخل عامل اساسي
اكثر من 65% من الحالات في جنوب اسيا
وافريقيا جنوب الصحراء
تلوث الهواء يساهم في سته ملايين ولاده
مبكره في كل عام
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات